el anuncio de la expulsión de 27
integrantes del personal de la embajada
y consulado español en rusia ha llegado
durante una reunión entre el ministerio
de asuntos exteriores ruso y el
embajador de españa en moscú es la
respuesta asimétrica que en madrid
habían estado esperando desde que el 5
de abril 'españa expulsar a la misma
cantidad de diplomáticos rusos la
expulsión de entonces que afectó al 60%
de la plantilla de la embajada de la
federación rusa en la capital española
fue la materialización del rechazo a la
invasión de ucrania iniciada a finales
de febrero y sobre todo a los posibles
crímenes de guerra cometidos por el
ejército liderado por la dimar kutin en
varias ciudades ucranianas como bucha o
boro dianca el embajador de españa en
rusia no se ha visto afectado por esta
decisión respuesta de moscú ya que
españa mantuvo en su puesto al jefe de
la delegación diplomática rusa en madrid
para dejar según el ministerio de
asuntos exteriores de españa jose manuel
alvar es una línea de diálogo abierta
entre ambos países el ministerio de
asuntos exteriores español ha rechazado
esta decisión de rusia que obliga a los
empleados a abandonar el país en una
semana los anuncios de moscú varios
países hostiles como los denomina el
kremlin se dan mientras finlandia y
suecia pretenden unirse a la otan un
proceso que han apoyado todos los países
integrantes del organismo excepto
turquía